hello and welcome to this video playing
the Pioneer with black know the peel I
don't know okay
let's him before it itself doesn't
really show whites cards can play all
kinds of stuff we should see five
whatever is a good move and I've had
this on the board a number of times
you can go on I have six but d6 is also
okay
an important
he said I don't have the knight on c6
which makes a difference in some lines
here for example in this gambit
continuation I am NOT going to put the
knight on to c6 but rather on to the
seven a bit surprised that he takes time
him
yeah what see yeah here for example
after some Bishop g5 which is five okay
okay
that said can only be
I mean here why do
yeah what is the point you just was for
nothing
weird okay
a rupee eight
and what would is right doing him
you
okay now how do we play
okay you can actually still castlelong
which is no weenie now coming to mine
coming to my attention
you
I had a city only only now I recognize
that
yeah then this whole stuff actually does
make some sense
Wow
you
[Music]
you
you
you
crazy
I mean this is really just bad opening
if I've said cannot go right I cannot be
right what on earth did I do here
you
Wow
you
with the rook Wow
very odd
we takes with the rock okay
[Music]
was there some really drawback
with the bishop I didn't quite spot that
goes back who really
he stole irritating me with this
Buddha's weird flame
was very considering 98 I know it looks
ridiculous but
you
Oh
you
III but it's b3
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
what a strange game
for
Stream liad
[Music]
now I know yeah I mean I'm sorry but I
don't I just don't believe this guy this
is just this is just hilariously
cheating him it was just total computer
stuff shut the beep off
obviously not and what an annoying idiot
sorry okay where is that I'm going to do
it live here what an idiot
I really don't don't know what does did
they waste their time they waste my time
our time what a friggin idiot
Magnus charts and yeah yeah all right
you're the greatest
so block report oh yeah okay cheat Ben
[Music]
cheater link to the game I can keep that
in I don't really mind that I it's a bit
silly I should I should have
I need the link yeah I need the link to
the game so that's a typical engine
cheating Emma where they play a
completely rubbish [ __ ] opening her
and then then all of a sudden they play
weird moves and you it through the whole
game of course yeah I can sell this is
going to be a ban and then we can we can
check the game quickly so let's check
the game and yeah the engine might give
some inaccuracies for whites opening
because it's rubbish but like this is
just not good so e5 is so relatively
relatively best it seems which might be
I mean it's this is not the human way to
play but might be the relatively best
Bishop f4 and now I had a total I mean a
total brain slip because I simply simply
forgot that he can castle long or that
it can Castle long so meaning
I mean having this in mind I should play
Bishop e6 and I'm a pawn up which is not
so easy it's easy to convert yeah I can
castle on King c8
you know at least here only chance you
get the points back and that is a good
thing so the points that you just rocked
me I will get back okay so long castles
kingi seven that I have to do this it
was kind of cleared I mean I defended
this quite reasonable aim I think a rook
takes this this was the point man you
that something is weird yeah rook takes
I mean
Bishop takes this is actually the more
engine move
I had an overt kind of engine he uses 9a
693 it's also very real move very
inhuman move this back and then the
realist move is b3 this is just
ridiculous
no human player would play b3 because it
does not it does not relate in any way
to the game before not at all it makes
absolutely no sense
so B 395 and now B should be six already
I overlooked Bishop d4 head to move that
of course is played immediately because
the engine shows that yeah the night at
six and then okay I made a mistake we
should be fired because I mean it was
blatantly obvious and it was an engine
so I was kind of irritated but yeah I
don't need to lose - I can play f6 or
something yeah I never know what you
know what to do with those games but I
mean if you meet somebody who calls self
the Pioneer yeah you can you can
ridicule him for cheating off us all the
time
a very good indicator is the bullet
rating of 1200 and then it's got blitz
rating 2,300 yeah who are you joking him
what what what a sick way look he will
get bant it's just a matter of time
ditches it's very quick in that so okay
thanks a lot for watching this somewhat
chest like game